an estimated three and a half million
spectators will be along the route of
today's 93rd Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade here in New York City we don't
know for sure if they'll get to see the
world-famous balloons but so far things
are going as planned
the parade begins along the west side of
Central Park and heads downtown ending
at 34th Street in Herald Square
Errol Barnett is at the beginning of the
two and a half mile route Errol
Happy Thanksgiving I know it's your
first this is my first Thanksgiving here
in New York City Michelle and I can tell
you British folks enjoy Thanksgiving
here in the u.s. just fine and there is
plenty of excitement in the air behind
me you can see a marching band Morgan
State from Baltimore Maryland and
everyone is ready for this to get going
the thought on everyone's mind though is
will these famous balloons fly they were
inflated late last night as of right now
they are scheduled to fly the NYPD
though can still call them off if wind
gusts do get above 34 miles an hour or
if they detect sustained winds above 23
miles an hour now among the amazing
sights and sounds during today's parade
are 11 marching bands from across the
country also 34 floats including a new
Lego float very close to my heart that
is among five of the new floats this
year and there are also 16 giant
character balloons ready to roll and get
this one of the chief the chief of
patrol told me yesterday his favorite
will be the triumphant return of Snoopy
as an astronaut that is to commemorate
the 50th anniversary of the moon landing
and on a more serious note the NYPD says
there are no known serious threats at
this moment but of course you've got
thousands of officers all along the
parade route ready to act should
something take place and as for the
parade itself that will feature a famous
tradition with Santa Claus towards the
end so you want to get the kids near the
TV and the great to see Santa the first
time this season
Errol we love that band behind you it's
not too cold out there is it no it's not
too bad it's pretty moderate these guys
are jamming moments ago but there's so
much talent and enthusiasm up and down
this parade route it's quite special for
me to be here folks thank you my take
lots of videos and clips for you guys do
it you got good to see you